現在台股很V喔
像趙華的領口一樣V
V到武漢缺口重回1萬2啦
我覺得應該快到季線壓力就很大
拉貨這種東西
你這波拉完之後
你還要不要繼續拉
你就可以預期到它四五月
已經說是掉下來啦
褲藏股
是不是可以來跟單跟一波呢
海水退了
才知道褲子藏的裡面是什麼東西
像這個XXX
一時失之後
主力買
對 要買了一萬多張了
股價的原理就在於獲利
一直賺錢
重點是現在是個機會
小哥我們今天玩點特別的
好 因為你看到有人賠玩
對 賠鬼了
兩位很懂玩的
來玩一下囉
玩一下
今天第一題好不好
就先開場
好
兩個V
當然趙懷今天也V啦
你那個不夠下面
不夠下面嗎
要拿兩個饅頭來墊嗎
這兩個V 你們喜歡哪個V
覺得台股應該是哪個V
先回答喜歡哪個V
當然是喜歡這個V
你這個照片出來的話
只要是正常的男的一定都選左邊啊
純骨派跟純馬派有目光集中的一天喔
我們在選女的
在選女的 不是股票
好 喜歡這個V
趙華就喜歡這個V
我跟他穿情侶裝
對 真的咧
是不是
因為你們異性相吸啊
我們也是異性相吸啊
所以選左邊啊
真的啊 哪裡吸到你們
要不要講一下
你知道看女生要先看哪裡嗎
先看哪裡喔
那你猜猜看
眼睛
你怎麼跟我想的一樣
真的喔
對 我都先看眼睛
因為趙華眼睛漂亮啊
沒有 我看她眼睛有沒有在看我
為什麼
假如沒有再看
我就可以看他胸部
胸部或大腿
好 看一下看一下
好 所以其實這一張是
等一下來解說
對 就是台股到底
這次V型反轉
會V到哪裡
對 其實這兩張圖啊
你看這女的有點五十肩
對
對不對 同性相繼
這V的太誇張了
V的太誇張了
那我們華仔的V咧
也有點高
也V的很勻稱
難道台股要回宮
去補武漢缺口嗎
我覺得很難啊
很難
好 很難嗎
短線很難
但是你如果是問我長線的話
我永遠就跟你講那一句話而已
長線永遠會創新高
不用怕
各位觀眾 有福囉
今天的理財達人秀的系列叫做
歌有仇必報
但是叫做骨魚特地來加持版
怎麼說呢
因為現在台股很V
像趙華的領口一樣V
可是很多人都會想說
為什麼這一波下去彈這麼快
第一 如果你还没有赚到钱
会很害怕喔
会觉得说会不会反转
或是直接就上冲
第二 当然你手上有股票也会想说
这个V看起来有点弱弱的
不知道会不会V回我们的武汉缺口
所以今天的单元会来教你两件事情喔
第一个 从筹码跟技术面来判断V到哪里
但是不管V到哪里
小哥都有解答喔
第二个就是从长线存股告诉你V到哪里
好 但是一樣 不管V到哪裡
谷魚會給你一個非常好的選標的方法
那現在先來考考兩位來賓
小哥谷魚剛剛已經選了
這個無庸置疑
但是這件事情要來說清楚了
小哥先回答好不好
是
當然現在已經沒有不V了的選項了
因為正在V嘛
都V了
好 V到跌幅的一半
超過了 感覺超過了
那也差不多了
會不會就V不下去對不對
V到武漢缺口 重回1萬2啦
我覺得應該超過一半
快到季線壓力就很大了
快到季線壓力就很大
對啊 現在已經在月線上面
月線也往上彎了
但是要到武漢缺口我覺得很難
很難 小哥你選圖跟選這個怎麼不一樣
你剛剛那個圖是這個耶
剛剛那個圖直接倒著肩膀
看女生當然是這個越下面越好
你說看到這個部位就好了是不是
看大盤要理智
要理智
看女生可以情感綿一點
好 谷魚呢
谷魚覺得V會到
現在是V到一半其實有點超過
會不會V好V滿
V好V滿
其實呢
當我在看這張圖的時候
我腦中有點想到W你知道嗎
第二隻腳
為什麼工程師的思路真的是
跟我們不一樣
沒有嘛
剛才女生就一個V
你把女生看成W還得了
沒有嘛
因為雖然我們是做那個
純古看長線嘛
可是我在長線這麼多的過程裡面
我真的很少看到
有人一V直接攻回到
原本的最高点上面去的
这个机率真的很困难
就刚刚小哥也有讲过了嘛
你看技术面跟存股面
来看这件事情的话
我们都觉得
要一次V到超过一万两千点
那个难度太高了
所以一旦冲不上去的时候
是不是就会下来
下来之后的话呢
而我又长线支持
它一定会收复原来的高点
那不就是一个W吗
哎哟
骨鱼的脑筋就是机器人的脑筋
他已经把后面两步推出来了
但是小哥你要讲理由
就是女生可以V
台股V不上
总要有点理由吧
我们来看一下
而且我们还是要给股民信心
V不上怎么办
我等一下来告诉大家
为什么
我们先看这个加权指数
它上面有一条季线
对
生命线
对 这生命线
生命线是往下的
所以代表往上
其实会有这个季线的反压
这一条季线其实还是往下的
还是往下的
第一個機械反壓
第二個呢
我們看全台股裡面
主力買賣超
在最近是比較多是在賣超
從籌碼來說
主力站在賣方
那誰在買
都散戶衝喔
目前看來只有投信在賣
投信在賣而已
但是以小哥來說
這麼多籌碼裡面
看這種籌碼是覺得不大好的
是不大好的
因為中石戶在上面來不及跑
對
但是在反彈的時候
他們就有警覺了
就賣掉
是
所以在现股部分
其实散户是在买的
期货上在放空
现股在买
为什么
因为现在有一堆散户
跑去券商开户了
这样散户还知道避险
它可能是两派散户
玩齐全的散户
跟玩现股的散户
玩现股散户
现在来开户
代表他们是怎么样
想要买啊
他们是很基础
平常没有买过股票
摩昌准备上阵
可是这些人
事實上他買股票
是比較沒有信心的
他在跌下來過程中
他們其實會很害怕
了解
那現在有信心的人
事實上是趁反彈的時候
在出貨
在出貨的
所以這個要比較注意一點
好 小哥從籌碼面上面
看到很多散戶
新開戶衝進來
你知道為什麼嗎
這些都是炮灰
不是炮灰
是看了你的純骨底bug
你是散戶明燈
散戶救星
對啊 你知道看你的多少就是
決定像骨魚一樣
要做場限出谷嗎
我管你是W
還是WWWWW
什麼都不怕嘛
終究會回到12000
沒有錯 這個心態就對了 健康
健康嘛
對 健康
可是你剛剛也是說啊
一開始可能會有點吃力
對對對
為什麼
會有點吃力嘛
因為啊 我覺得呢
這一波要能夠那麼快的反轉回去
不是這麼容易的
蛤
對 你這種看到12000、13000
都是你在海台
還告訴我台股上2萬的人這樣講
會有點擔心
會擔心
對
可是這是有原因的
基本面有什麼狀況
你知道嗎
那個3月的營收
基本上各價已經全部都發布了
對
那我們去看啊
股價能不能夠繼續上工
營收很重要
很重要啊
還是有創新高的啊
創新高嘛
你知道嗎
創虛的新高是沒有用的
什麼叫虛的新高
這人看不得人家好而已
不是不是
我們幫你把資料都整理好了
你知道嗎
整個3月份
營收創新高的公司
1700多間公司裡面
只有52檔
也是難免嘛
第一季很多公司
其實到了3月
已經是第一季的尾巴
比較淡嘛
可是你知道嗎
散戶很單純啊
我今天看到公司營收
一直衰退一直衰退
沒有創新高的話
股價怎麼繼續往上衝呢
而且3月已經有疫情了
它還能創新高
這不是代表它疫君突起很強嗎
當然不是啦
他們只是剛好是受惠股而已
所以我們這個就要講清楚了
在這一片哀鴻聲之中
為什麼我們覺得要繼續V上去
V到最高點很難的原因是
因為這一波的受惠股
主要是兩個族群
第一個族群叫做疫情受惠股
比如說像恆大
題材而已啊
題材股嘛 你也知道嘛 對不對
是不是疫情過了之後
就要打回原型了
現在APP都可以釘口罩了
是嘛 對不對
那另外一種的話
這個投資人比較沒注意到
叫做提前拉貨股
這個我有聽說
有聽過嗎
我有聽說
大陸那邊有人真的提早
跟我們的半導體的大廠拉貨
平民拉貨嘛
因為你知道嗎
之前在2月份
我們在討論這波疫情的時候
大家最擔心什麼
斷鏈零組件斷料所以你要擔心斷鏈斷料的話那是不是提前拉貨那很簡單,三月就反映了所以你看這一波創新高的個股的話
基本上就兩個族群
要嘛賣口罩的
要嘛賣耳溫槍的
要嘛就是這些做半導體族群的
都是這一些
所以我現在聽到半導體的好消息
我先不要開心對不對
因為你知道嘛
拉貨這種東西,你這波拉完之後
就不用了啊
就要休息了嘛
所以你也許你就可以預期到
四五月營收就掉下來啦
喔 對不對
但是你看那麼空啊
沒關係
今天好不好
小哥他說短線還是有一些股票是不錯的
喔 對啦
因為其實這個就
涉及到長線跟短線的觀點是不太一樣的
為什麼小哥說今天長線短線
其實我們今天有一個很好的主題喔
因為小哥要幫我們篩
因為大家聽完說不V了
那我幹嘛看這集 我何必買
沒 當然不會是這樣
趙華不會隨便放過達人們好不好
所以今天小哥跟古瑜要來PK一件事喔
什麼事情 因為小哥覺得庫藏鼓
好不好 因為現在很多時事庫藏鼓的
他們真的有在真金白銀的買喔
那是不是可以來跟單跟一波呢
但是我又記得以前古瑜說過
庫藏鼓都是嘴炮而已
到底誰說得對 我們先來問問小哥喔
好 裤装骨有效 真的有效
先看这个八爷爷讲的这句话
海水退了才知道谁没有穿裤子
有啊 我们常常在讲这句啊
骨鱼也会用这句啊
这句话呢 八爷爷这样讲
哎哟 小哥 我知道你看八爷爷
你不喜欢犯了
八爷爷年轻的时候是这样的
八爷爷年轻的时候在海滩拍的照片
他那时候不是讲这句啊
他那时候是说
海水退了才知道裤子藏的里面是什么东西
對 按照小哥說的啊
褲長股不是都是嘴炮啊
你怎麼不可能褲子脫的裡面什麼都沒有吧
沒有啊 你要看清楚褲長股的內容是什麼啊
好啊 我看清楚啊 對不對
褲長股這種東西
我們先來聊一下市場的現況
其實這一波下跌下來
褲長股的加速
一開始新聞報6加
我第二次看到說報32加
我昨天打開一看的時候
200加
200加 總會有好貨吧
當然啊
你說這麼多公司裡面
當然挑還是會挑到一些好貨嘛
可是呢我們要先了解
庫廠股的本質到底是什麼
所以我們簡單的作用
本質不就是公司覺得我股票好便宜
所以我趕快買啊
那當然不是啊
庫廠股它有幾個功用
首先第一個
買了之後轉換給員工
好棒喔
第二個
作為轉換股權之用
這第二個
第三個的話呢
這個最常聽到了
維護公司信用
它这个转换股权之用是什么意思
转换股权之用吗
就是呢
它有可能把库长股买了之后
它去发行其他新的产品
比如说发行CB啦
或是说做抵押啦
或是说资金活化很好啊
是是是是
可是呢
我们这一波下来里面
你看到最多的
大部分都是这个
维护公司信用
我跟你讲
很简单
就是大股東拿錢護自己的盤
很棒啊
就跟國安基金幫我們護大家的盤一樣啊
問題是它護盤的眼光有時候不太好啊
你看喔
你如果今天就要維持公司信用的時候
是不是應該在股價的最低點護盤
可是股價最低點的時候
也蠻多家說實施庫藏股啊
沒有啊
可是它實際進場的時候
有些還在辦商家
它越買就越跌了啊
對不對
那像這種
你去護這個盤是沒什麼用的
而且最重要是什麼你知道嗎
你以為它真的會買好買滿
你會不會想太多
我在以前研究公司庫藏股的時候
最常看到我現象是什麼
我今天說要買1萬張
搞半天只買了500張就收工了
會不會有那種說要買1萬張
搞不好大股都買3萬張
不可能 吃點肉的
不可能啦 不可能啦
我最常看到的就是
絕不買好買滿的這個最多
我第一次看到谷魚
對於公司買股票
站得那麼反方的耶
他真的是散戶的救星
他是永遠站在散戶那一邊的
公司買股票以籌碼來說就是
公司派在買不是很棒嗎
對 沒錯
所以古瑜到我這樣說對不對
我現在趙華在這邊兩邊拉鋸
你知道一邊是愛情
一邊也是愛情
其實兩邊都有情啦
我現在很掙扎 對
那個庫藏股呢
其實我們可以看得出來
他到底有沒有在買
因為現在有籌碼可以看
對
那我們也可以從
第一個我們從點位位階來判斷一下
這個點位位階高的話呢
它這種實施庫償股有的就是
嘴炮型的
所謂的點位位階
我要怎麼判斷高跟低
例如說像以前的國具啊
從一兩百塊跌到一千三
跌到九百塊
它就說要實施庫償股
漲到一千三跌到九百塊
就要實施庫償股
離一兩百還很遠
還很遠
那這種很遠
我們就看年限乖離
好 你看年限乖離
你離年限很遠
你就知道
這可能不是真心的
這可能是維護大股東的權益
不是股東權益
第一種就是完全配合股與獎的
符合他的判斷
第二個我們可以看關鍵分點
看公司進場了沒
有沒有真買
現在都有籌碼的軟體可以看
或這個政要所都有公布
沒錯
全世界台灣最幸福
那你就可以看
第三個我們再看
它庫長股14的量跟它的均量的比較
怎麼比呢
据来说假设这个均量只有500张
对
库长股刷141万张
那就会买喷啦
对11万张
那他假如真的有在买的话
那这档股票呢
最能就会比较强一点
所以他还是要回到第二点
对
他嘴巴上说他要买那么多
可是事实上有没有真的买
对我们可以去查看看
好
看他有没有真的买
所以这三种不一样
对
我们要怎么分啊
因为这三种对我来说差很大
我今天用...
你會覺得褲子打開
裡面東西差很多
我今天用很淺顯的話
就可以讓你聽得懂了
好
好,來看一個
第一個,庫廠股第一類
第一類
低檔實施庫廠股
是
在低檔的時候買
實施的時候主力會買超
長期來看呢
實施的時候相對的低點
這種低類就是
公司吃了股票之後
公司吃了之後呢
股價會怎麼樣
股價會硬
我們是理財節目
股價會噴
對 你看
這低點他吃了
哇 股價就暈了
那在這邊
這低點吃了就找上去
低點吃了後面還不知道
後面還不知道
但是這邊就是低點
然後這邊主力
低點吃 主力買
好
像這個低點吃
最近分點也有在買
也有在買
就是低檔實施庫藏股
這個就是吃了會硬
對 這種就是有信用
有信用
對 吃著會映著有信用的股票
就是股雲也有少數的公司啦
對 少數的公司
好 那我們可以看一下
它這邊有會寫說
本次已買回的比率
照過往2012年買73%
哇 蠻高的
14年買94%
買好買滿
15年買比較少
對
16年買95%
所以我們可以看它過往的
這個信譽好不好
信譽好不好
信用的信
这个信誉蛮强的
信用很好
恩不是恩
要分清楚
信誉好不好
这过往怎么样
不错
信誉不错
就是有奖有买
这我们比较喜欢
不到买到满
还满到慢出来了
对
买了之后
后面股价就印了
来看第二个
像华欣
华欣
华欣是低档实施
好
各位看一下
這粉紅色是實施的時候
最近又實施了
現在這個粉紅色是因為我們順時鐘嗎
順時鐘
對 你看我今天
你也穿粉紅色
對啊
超應景的
為了小學生口罩戴粉紅色被霸凌
我們都特別穿一個粉紅色襯衫
有心有心
不要怕
這個華新最近也在買
也是在低檔
然後華新的分點
這個可以透露一下
華新家族的
因為他們也不會變
都在元大管钱
就在我们公司东森的旁边
对
就好像华欣家族
华欣科什么
你就看元大管钱
看他有没有在买
元大管钱
有在买
有在买就不错了
好
所以这是第一类
第一类
小哥透露了
如果你是看到第一类的
他说要实施库藏股
过去的季度都给你买好买满
而且他只要一买
股价通常在低点会往上
这种库藏股是真的
古瑜也认为是真的
所以先學好這件事情
那第二類呢
好 第二類呢
我們就要趨吉避凶了對不對
對 第二類呢
高檔實施庫藏股
高檔還什麼
高檔就怪怪的啊
你只有奪愛自己公司啊
對啊 這個人
這個人怪怪的然後實施的時候主力持續的賣超不是在實施嗎對他一邊實施公司真的在買喔
公司他用自己的資金買
所以公司看來在買
可是好像有外圍一直在到貨喔
是跟他對還是
趁著這個庫長股出貨
那後面呢繼續跌
那這種股票呢
我們就叫他什麼你知道嗎
叫他什麼
吃的不會硬
公司吃的不會硬
公司派吃了股票之後
股票不會硬
我們來看一下
國巨在實施的時候
在這個點實施
對
你看一下它實施的時候
主力都在幹嘛
都在到貨
都在賣超
它從1200 1300塊
這個跌到800 900塊
就說要實施庫藏股
連線上實施庫藏股
但主力卻狂賣
太奇怪了
騙散戶來接棒嘛
對 騙散戶接
而且這個國巨
這個實施完呢
給你看一下
實施完它之後的結果
它在這邊實施
這個地方也跌了一段了啦
一路
它是實施的時候
一路買
因為實施兩個月嘛
對
它一邊買一邊跌
一邊買一邊跌
為什麼因為主力一路賣
如果光看表面會覺得
國劇越跌它就越戶
越戶
越維護自己公司是好的啊
對 我們來看一個分點
因為我們去抓這段時間
買的分點是誰
有個分點呢
這群藝的抹分點
在這邊真的有買
它真的有買
各位你看這裡有買
到後面它還是賣掉了
所以它只是讓大家覺得
我說好像有做到
事實上立刻偷偷賣掉
後面有賣
最重要的是主力在這邊一直到
我覺得這種公司我就不大欣賞了
這種公司你看它十支庫藏股的時候
很壞
人家現在在發海外信脫層證
存脫凭证
一直不大
你看他实施的时候
他写他的目的
转让股份与员工
然后买回区间
他写个1616.8
他是觉得一路一路会发
对
根本没有这数字好不好
因为1616
这个1000多块
就不是.8这种数字了
所以这数字根本是宣示用
宣示用的
就宣示跟散户讲说
你有可能會看到這個數字喔
因為1300跌下來嘛
對
所以我告訴你
你1300套的人
你也不要急喔
我搞不好給你買回1600
對
這樣子說實話
總結小哥的話
很壞耶
這種就是吃的不會硬的
吃的不會硬
吃的不會硬這種不喜歡
好
再看另外一檔
這檔也是一樣
難怪骨魚你也不喜歡嘛
因為看到太多不硬的嘛
對啊
因為通常都是做假褲場的很多
假褲場的
假褲場 好
來 這個是第二類
第二類就吃了不會硬
吃了不會硬就很遜啦
難道還有比這個更差的嗎
比這好一點的
又有一點興趣了
實施庫腸骨時骨架有撐
吃的時候是在硬
然後結束庫腸骨後骨架疲軟
這大部分男人都有這個
怎麼叫大部分男人
我們這邊才兩個男子
除了兩位之外
對 你這樣講
好 这种叫预证法力型
是
像国产啊
买的时候有涨
你看他买的时候真的有涨
买的时候真的有涨
现在买的时候真的有在涨
这种买的时候涨
这种啊
你要看一看他库长股要买到何时
但是他有没有可能
他一买我就买嘛
然后涨一点我就卖啊
可是我们也可以来做短线啊
你可以做价差可以
但是你记得时间到了
取终人善
它是买的时候涨
没买就跌了
这种就只能过一夜
当下好好把握那两个月的时间
当伴侣就
要思考一下
就不大好
像古鱼都是选人家当伴侣的
所以他都会好好选
小哥很棒
小哥还帮我们趋吉避凶
因为还是有好的
第一类的
他随便吃随便印
印了就一直印下去
那当然也有另外两类
就像你讲的
可能吃了才会硬
或吃了就一路软下去的也有
所以我不管啦
因为还是有第一类的嘛
所以就你基本面来看的话
一定也有实施库长谷
它的信誉也很好
当然有啊
然后呢
股价又配合它的体质
又会涨上去的
因为其实库长谷这种东西
某种程度上
我们关注的点
跟筹码的点
是差不多的
所以今天是
纯骨派跟筹码派的大和解吗
不能说大和解
虽然说我们切入的角度不同
可是我们关心的重点是一样的
股价要会涨
对嘛 股价要涨了之后
你这个实施库长股才有意义
所以你看像刚刚小哥讲的
有三个种类
其中有一种的话是真的去库长
而且真的会涨
我们要找的重点就是那一个
就是那一个的好公司
对 好公司
那你从存股的角度上面来讲的话
其实我们也是一直在找这种好公司
而且你还会再帮他加一个防护罩
因為你還會再去從財報上確認它
公司有信用 買了會漲
而且體質其實是好的
對...這就是切入的角度不太一樣
所以我們先來看一下
其實庫藏股這三個字
對散戶有很大的意義
怎麼說?
定心丸
對 你知道嗎
我在外面跑來跑
就是遇到好多投資人
他看到庫藏股三個字
人都嗨起來了 你知道嗎
那就不是你鐵粉
不是...
你鐵粉就知道你...
你知道為什麼會嗨起來的原因嗎
他就覺得說
大戶自己都進來買股票了
我今天小戶跟著進去買
肯定不會輸嘛
我也常這樣覺得
不過小哥講完之後我得到開示
我只能跟第一類
就是O-In的大戶
所以你只有1 3分之1會中而已
講實際點就這個樣子
沒關係 我靠你
所以我們來看一下
如果你真的要搶進庫長股
還是有重點的
首先我們第一個先來看一下
跟小哥完全相同看法的
這個說到做到
說到做到
對不對
就是說你今天你要執行庫廠股的話
你的比例最好是
譬如說你要買五千張
你最好每次都給我買五千張
有信用的
那其實也會公告
每一次他也沒有買好買滿
對對對
他會公告的
所以你如果是挑到這種
有信用的公司
那就OK嘛
像剛剛講到那個紅插電
對不對
那個後來的信用就不好了
不用插電大家都知道了
沒有插電了
對對對
所以這個要注意
所以就是要持續獲利囉
最好是成長的
而且呢
說到又做到
對
這個是我們從基本面的角度來看的話
這兩點超重要的
好
所以呢
你看喔
像這種訊息的話呢
找不找得到
可以啦
證交所的重大訊息裡面
就可以找得到
他執行的狀況了
他有執行的狀況
就剛剛小哥講的
他到底有沒有執行
然後公告最後
他到底有沒有買好買滿
對
執行比例是多少
全部都可以查得到
所以這些都是一些
很公開的訊息啦
對不對
所以接下來
好不好
我不查了啦
因為我知道骨魚都會幫我查好
我們都是被凹要去查這些資料的
不然我的價值在哪裡
對 穿V又贏不了別人
不要這個樣子
只好用威脅的
所以我們來看一下
我們剛剛前面有提到嘛
庫長股有200多家嘛
對啊
好 那200多家裡面的話呢
我們前面有提到
第一個要有信用
對
然後第二個的話呢
獲利有可能會增加的
對
所以我們先來看
你做好表了
表
我根本早就做好了
你每次手拿上來
都會有客訴
會有客訴是不是
哎呀客訴啊客訴啊
欸欸欸欸
態度對好一點
好好來講一下怎麼樣
所以這張就可以買是不是
沒有啊
如果這張就可以買的話呢
那錄到這邊就結束了嘛
對不對
肯定不是的
我們實在跟你講說呢
你在這種庫長股裡面的話呢
首先你要注意的是
它有沒有比上個月繼續增長
好現在是三月營收出來
這是有的
可是還要再看一下4月營收對不對
4月營收的話那是下個月的事情
可是我們在這個時間點注意兩件事
第一個有沒有比上個月增長
這是第一個要注意的
第二個的話有沒有比去年同期增長
尬 等一下 有炸耶
哪裡有炸
這邊全部都是正的啊
跟去年同期比就一堆負的耶
你現在也喜歡出陷阱題耶
我沒有出陷阱題
我們這叫做提示
小哥他的特色就是陷阱題
所以整理出來的資料
我們要先小心的檢驗
不是小心的檢驗嘛
所以其實你這麼多的庫長谷裡面的話
你把資料攤開一看
你會發現
其實雖然很多家公司
都叫上個月營收大幅增長
可是很多家也都跟去年同期
大幅度的衰退
這是營收裡的陷阱
大家要注意哦
不是看到營收好消息
你就覺得可以衝進去哦
營收好消息
其實你要跟去年同期再比一次
其實很多根本就是壞消息
你知道為什麼3月營收
幾乎都一定會增長嗎
當然因為1、2月有遇到過年啊
遇到過年嘛
對啊 遇到過年的話
還不增長還得了啊 對不對
所以你就會發現
如果有人在3月營收是衰退
這邊公司根本就丟到旁邊去了嘛是不是好 所以這個是告訴大家營收很重要可是營收看對更重要對 一定要看對這一張表裡面應該要再篩一次要再篩一次啊這是一定的嘛 對不對
所以我們的重點
一定要找到兩個都成長的
YA 大家等到真正的
叫做古魚只看三家
現在古魚拿的第一張表
我們都不要仔細看
幹嘛這樣 都先看第二張
幹嘛這樣 幹嘛這樣
我們都是配合節目
來做一些篩選嘛
看教育啦
對 教育
要注意一下营收的陷阱在哪裡
所以最好要找到什麼
如果有實施庫藏股
那它比三月
三月比二月來的增長
而且它又比去年同期
再繼續做增長了
這個才是完真的
所以這三家有這樣的現象
可是這邊趙華要提醒大家
因為我們推的股票不是說
買啊買啊買啊
然後就會一堆人說怎麼被套了啦
或是賺很多謝謝你
其實這不是我們的用意
用意是我們按照標準挑出來
希望大家都能照著去挑出你喜歡的好股票
而且這三家公司
你知道為什麼我故意挑它嗎
為什麼
因為它的財報良好啊
對不對
哇 古魚幫我們先看過財報了
當然啊 財報要看完之後
才敢秀給各位看嘛 對不對
你今天實行庫廠股
但是體質爛得一塌糊塗
或是說公司本身沒有賺錢
你知道嗎 股價驅動的原力在哪裡
原力你知道是什麼嗎
原利是我們的星際大戰裡的原利
黑五世的原利
原利與我同在
對
股價的
股價的原利呢就在於獲利
一間公司不賺錢的話
那是股價沒有支撐的啦
我們看長線的好不好
博文好機會
你看我們現在看過去有沒有一直賺錢
一直賺錢
好
營收的所謂的毛利率、營業率、淨利率
有沒有一直維持甚至上升
對這邊有一個是比較急的上升
那下來又再上升上去了
對對對
所以這個就是
三綠喔
這是穩定上升了嘛
所以這個就是
你從財務面來看的話呢
這是一個基本上良好的一個判斷
獲利上升 三綠也上升
而且呢
重點是現在是個機會
怎麼機會 怎麼機會
柯博文耶
這個是變形金剛
柯博不是啊
什麼機會
這波不是有疫情嗎
對啊
疫情不是大家跌得一塌糊塗
是 但是又V到上來了
對嘛
你今天遇到庫長谷
你不是想逮机会吗
当然啊 不然请你来做什么
那我们逮机会的话呢
其实库长股对我来讲不是很重要
我们一定都是从基本面在看的
好
当然你今天有库长股的话呢
也许它的股价走得比较稳
甚至回得比较快
我知道我怎么读过你的盲点了
什么盲点
库长股有信心吗
你只好又有信心
加上等一下小哥用筹码告诉你
好不好 主力大户真的在加持
所有的事情加在一起
这股票真的不长也难
不长也难嘛
而且你看哦
我们通常你从基本面
我们最喜欢遇到什么事情
知道吗
好体质遇到坏事件
这个我赞同
你赞同嘛对不对
那遇到坏事件的时候
就会出现什么
好价格
好价格对投资人就是什么意思呢
好机会
所以你看我们现图里面的话呢
我们一旦把它的
用财务面去做估价之后
有没有
是不是机会就浮现了
所以它其實已經跌了一大段
即使台股在V
它其實相對於它的體質來說
它也是很好的股票
它是很好的股票
等你繼續再回溫
甚至說你庫長股的部分
繼續發酵的話
這個很快就回去了
這樣是不是一個很良好的機會
這是三之一嘛
因為剛剛有三檔
三之二
沒有 我們不能夠
擔用節目太久的時間
兩檔是不是
我只幫你介紹兩檔就好了
一檔是要大家自己回去慢慢查
好不好
今天教的大家慢慢查
因為我一直說
我們這是個教學節目
教學節目當然留點功課回去給觀眾自己做
上電視不要教太多
告訴大家答案就好了
台郡的話一路賺而且越賺越多
這是獲利的曲線
超棒的吧
而且你看山立也是一路拼命往上攻
毛利率、盈益率跟盡利率
一路都往上攻
而且最重要是在這波疫情的打擊之下
股價也有修正
而且它就會出現一個所謂的
好的機會就跑出來了
所以我們常常會講說
這波疫情的打擊
對很多投資人來講興奮
你知道嗎
疊下來的時候
好多人傳私訊給我
你知道嗎
等一下什麼疫情帶來的打擊
不要興奮好不好
哀今勿喜
真的嗎
偷偷撿骨
可是我的私訊裡面
都充滿了興奮之氣
你知道嗎
說我等了好幾年
終於這波機會來了
是不是小哥你看
純骨派其實就是嗜血派
對 因為他們好幾年才開機一次
幹嘛這樣
好幾年才硬一次
不要小哥
不要小哥天天都有得硬
我們比較短一點
對
我們看庫長谷
這個會看的面比較少
我們只要怎麼樣
只要他正在吃
正在吃
主力正在買
對 然後呢
然後他有翹就可以了
我是說上軌好不好
上軌
不凌通道的上轨有翘就好了
不凌通道上轨有在翘
主力有在买
库长股分点也有在买
只要符合这三个
我们就享受
他库长股期间的涨幅就好了
等于说短期的快乐
这样就够了
库长股快要结束的时候
就赶快跟他说再见
等一下我知道
小哥一定热爱一夜情
長期的快樂要加上主於
一條體質
短期的快樂有效就快樂了
所以我們要特別注意什麼東西
第一個我們要特別注意它買賣的時間
買賣的時間
買賣時間都有公告
我只是幫各位列出來而已
像這個是3月26到5月25
通常都兩個月
所以越接近
快結束了
趕快跑
因为这种股票
它可能长期都是
主力在卖的
只是因为最近
公司派买回来
变成主力买超
所以这种呢
我们就跟它玩短线就好
对 这也不到一夜情啦
但它就是一个
两个月的
就是这些是
寒假或暑假的练期
对 没错
再来看第二档
像这个集胜啊
集胜呢
元大某分点
你看之前主力在出货
对
一实施之后
一公告实施
粉红这段时间
主力买
真的大買耶
對 竹力買
然後呢 他真的大買
他買了一萬多張了
然後呢 這個他上軌也翹了
上軌也翹了
對 好
像這種呢
其實你咬在低檔參與的話
最近漲滿多的
好 有享受到這個短期的歡愉啦
對 再來看這個嘉白玉
嘉白玉呢 他之前也有食庫長谷
對
結果你看啊
他就是呢 吃的時候呢 怎麼樣
主價有漲 結果會笑
一不吃 就又軟了
又軟了
那股價又軟了
最近又吃了又翹了
所以你要特別看
5月26號
看他有沒有一直在吃對不對
然後你還要看他預訂買回的張數
對
這4千張喔
那你用籌碼軟體你看
哇 他現在買1千多張了
還有大概2千多張要買
你可能就要看一下
這段時間前1、2、3名的分點
都要看一下
因為他公司可能不只一個分點在賣
那加一加超過快4千張了
趕快離場
他們已經不吃了
不吃了 股價可能就會修正
那如果保守一點
是不是不見得要等到4000
例如2000 3000
開心就好
因為我也不知道
他會不會繼續吃
有享受到那段漲幅就好了
我覺得古瑜你要學一下
久久開心一次
不如小哥天天開心
對
我們是洗澡長期的伴侶
所以兩邊的門派
其實我發現今天來
本來以為他們兩個PK的
結果小哥跟古瑜
其實意外的
他們兩個有一個交合點
他們兩個其實可以變麻吉
就是怎麼樣
庫長股有沒有用
其實短線上是有用的
但是你要挑對公司
小哥從籌碼面來看
如果你買到
公司派持續買進
有信用的公司
它會漲
那股魚一樣啊
體質好
你有十日庫長股
它當然會繼續漲啊
所以兩邊有了一個交融
所以在這麼多好的老師
來教我們的理財達人秀呢
千萬不要忘記
我們有精英班哦
所以喜歡我們的內容的話
記得到理財達人秀的
YouTube频道
去订阅我们的精英班
或是按这边
按这边
好不好
那今天非常谢谢
两位大师
一个就是我们的小哥
哥友仇必报
他们的骨鱼
存骨抵霸的合体
来告诉你
酷长骨传的
真的是这样做就有效
那各位观众朋友
如果有任何的意见
想要留言给我们
也欢迎到我们
YouTube频道来留言
那我们的理财达人秀
就下礼拜再见咯
拜拜
字幕志愿者 杨茜茜